if you listen to music these days you
know this rap flow love it
you're in luck it's probably not going
away anytime soon if you hate it I'm
sorry but hey you have something in
common what Snoop Dogg now everybody try
to rap the same stab which I don't know
who created if it was future amigos but
all them [ __ ] sound the same that
rapid fire style of rap has been dubbed
the meiko's flow even the Versace flow
it's come to define mainstream artists
in recent years but the musical
principle that drives that flow the
triplet it's been around forever in 2013
Miko's the Atlanta rap trio released a
song called from Sachi I'm just gonna
pause that for a second
Drake loved it so much he freestyled
over it wanted to run over sometimes I
feel like a menace and it blew up
you can't deny Versace like my grandma
would walk around singing Versace and
she didn't even know like the words the
song it was about but the hook is so
catchy that's how big of a song it was
that's Justin hi you might know him as
the former editor-in-chief of HipHopDX
he covers hip hop trends and news on his
YouTube channel and so I think you have
like a lot of forces that's just sort of
combined at the right time for that flow
finally to make it to Providence even
those origins have been around for a
while
triplets are a standard in musical
composition they occur when you divide
one beat into three notes instead of the
usual two or four recognize this
[Music]
that's probably the most famous measure
with triplets but they go back even
further these are types of rhythms that
have been at the foundation of cultures
where hip-hop came from in the first
place its African rhythms and so that's
as old as the equator in rap triplets
worked the same way just take a listen
to young thug's get high featuring Snoop
Dogg now compare that to another point
in the song where there are new triplets
bubblegum cookies oh gee and cake cake
we like Craig and date-date who gives a
[ __ ] what they say and you start to hear
the difference it's hard to say exactly
when the first triple it was wrapped but
a lot of people point to Public Enemies
bring the noise as one of the earliest
examples another track with triplets in
1987 the disc masters small-time hustler
triplets
existed during the East Coast West Coast
era of hip-hop but they didn't really
define those artists they actually
emerged out of the Midwest and the south
when those communities started
developing their own style like that
Ohio down the Tennessee corridor there
was a lot of stylistic similarities
through a few of the different artists
just listen to this crazy bone verse off
of Bone Thugs and harmonies debut album
that flow stand in stark contrast to the
way eazy-e approached the same beat on
that song and then there's three 6 mafia
from Memphis I think it's very difficult
to give anyone else credit other than
Lord infamous mystic Styles is the joint
that I remember really early right the
third he's another artist from Memphis
as well he had a song called gangster
forever all these artists released their
debut albums in the mid 90s and they
weren't just rapping fast they were
manipulating the theme with triplets so
how exactly did they pull it off well
you have to look at the structure of the
beat for triplets to really eventually
come and be so famous they needed to
steal the show and is steal the show
they needed their own space that's
Martin Connor you might remember him
from these two videos so you can create
a hip-hop beat in a couple of different
ways this is the beat and I can
interpret this beat though in a rap song
in two different ways I can go either
buh buh buh buh [ __ ] or I could go like
this buh buh buh okay but my snaps have
always come at the same speed
right but the snare drums they come half
as often giving the rapper more space to
play notorious thugs illustrates this
perfectly and it's also one of my
favorite songs so I just want to talk
about it
[Music]
this instrumental sounds like a slow
down tempo beat that's because we're
used to counting the snare on the two
and the four
the actual BPM though is double the
speed and the snare hits on b3
[Music]
essentially the instrumental beat has
two rhythmic lanes for the artist to rap
in Big E Bizzy Bone crazy bone they all
keep you on your toes by constantly
changing those lanes because the beat is
stretched out and feel slow they can
very naturally divide those notes
farther into triplets let's switch back
to Lord infamous
of three 6 mafia that slow beat allowed
him to rap an entire verse in triplets
from the 90s til the mid 2000 southern
hip hop artists slowly took over the
charts and with that they brought with
them the sound of traps that stretched
out beat is the foundation of the trap
sound but you'll also hear a deep 808
kick drum driving sense and a rapid-fire
hi-hat that is often programmed in
triplet patterns triplets were always in
rap and then triplets were waiting for
trap music to come along and then trap
music came along and like it was just a
marriage made in heaven a song like
Versace made the sound and rhythmic feel
of triplets just super catchy just
listen to how that hook plays back and
forth with those explosive high hats 5
years later and it's pretty easy to see
why triplets are migos his bread and
butter
I don't think that me ghost is gonna
trail off or fall off I think they have
legitimate star power and most
importantly I think they put together an
incredible album this year not only that
they've been featured on tracks by some
of the biggest artists of today triplets
aren't just popular though they're
really complex the triplets sort of
challenges the rhythms and the counts
that we're used to they can rev up the
energy of a song almost instantly
Kendrick used them on good kid maad city
and then five years later on one of the
most dramatic moments of damn
[Music]
[Music]
Chancellor opera has a similar dramatic
transition to triplets on the opening
track of coloring book when he starts
flowing in triplets there are no snare
drums there are no bass kicks so what
its chance do but he makes the triplet
the manifestation of the beat these are
two of the biggest artists outside of
the south
using triplets they're no longer a niche
southern style they have been dominating
the sound of hip hop for over five years
now when a rapper does that rhythm all
of a sudden they're tapping into this
greater collective artistic movement so
snoots not entirely wrong that's what's
wrong writing everybody trying to rap
the same style with I don't know created
if it was future amigos but all don't
make a sound the same but he kind of
misses the point the fact that triplets
are super popular now shouldn't
undermine the fact that they're actually
a really powerful rhythmic tool that's
been around for a long time
[Music]
[Applause]
you